all right Mike so you and I got a chance
to check out the super hot beta I feel
like I gotta do a valley girl
interpretation every time super hot are
you here in the game they say it three
times at the end of every mission super
hot super hot this is after you've staff
five guys in a row and shot some dudes
matrix style but I digress in general
how are you feeling about super hot in
this beta phase conceptually it's really
cool it's kind of a new conceit as far
as time mechanic let's go it's time only
moves when you move which is interesting
because if you're aiming it'll move
pretty slowly but if you just full-on
walk to the right the enemy enemies will
walk as well and then also you can kind
of if you move slow enough inch by inch
you can dodge bullets I know you were
bunny hopping a lot to try to give her
the bullets I found a way to reload the
best matter we love my weapon was just
bunny hopping and every time I landed my
gun was like ready to go again but that
would advance time it's interesting
because it allows you to do a lot more
tactical thinking and plan out your
strategy but at the same time even
looking around would advance the clock
ever so slightly so you would have to be
very careful and strategic with how you
move and you were under pressure I mean
if they fired a bullet it would be
slowly traveling towards you and you
would have to figure out you know okay
I'm gonna dodge right but then there's a
dude with the shotgun they're working
dodge left but you know I have an
assault rifle and if I fire this assault
rifle it advances time differently than
other weapons
so the end of every round is
simultaneously my favorite part of this
game and also my least favorite part of
this game the part where it shows what
you did in real time makes you feel like
a matrix badass but then at the same
time that's where the whole
meta-narratives comes into play and
anytime that was on screen I wanted to
have a seizure yeah it was sort of
annoying at first and it was kind of
reminded me of Bioshock or Stanley
parable where the narrator is kind of
breaking the fourth wall and talking to
you but in this case it was really
really kind of obscure and esoteric and
I felt like a lot of it was just
stopping me from starting the next level
right away and it's a fast paced game
despite the fact that I move slowly a
lot and I really want to just get into
the next level but there was this weird
kind of barrier between myself and the
game that I felt like the developers
replacing there but then after a while
we kind of started to figure out that
there were a few more things that
narrative than meets the eye you found
some things that I did not yeah it's
still a beta so I think they're trying
to figure out what their easter eggs or
secret missions are going to be some of
the things that I noticed in the game
are there are servers on every level
that you can destroy so many of you
won't get some kind of alternate ending
if you've destroyed all the servers in
the story there's also weird things like
if you go off mission you'll find a
television where you can watch yourself
you know playing around the television
there was a random fan in one point that
had no purpose that I could tell and
then the developer also had some secret
messages they would flash like there's
going to be something here in the full
game you know check back later that's so
I think it would be really cool if they
could you know dial down just the screen
effects in the storytelling a little bit
and then hopefully this these extra
secrets will come into play because
it'll make you want to do the levels
differently oh you know another thing
also that I think the game can do which
it isn't doing yet is I noticed that the
bad guys do have a vision cone and they
don't get they don't always get AG road
so maybe special rewards for stealth
play thurs I didn't know too
I didn't get any message that I was
getting a reward for self play thurs but
it seems like super hot has a lot of
directions it could grow in if they just
kind of refine these mechanics and tone
down the visual effects on the
storytelling yeah I think there's a
great foundation there and the gameplay
can see of time not moving until you do
is really cool and I like that you
brought up the stealth because I was
I've been playing a few other stealth
games right now and it would be cool the
fact that time is moving so slowly I
think would make it a lot more tense if
you're moving in slow motion or at least
advancing time between slow motion and
you're just worried like oh [ __ ] is he
gonna see me right now or not am I going
to be able to avoid a gunfight but I
kind of agree with you right now as far
as that overarching storyline goes I
feel like it's just them trying to force
something on me because the game is so
bare-boned right now as it is I think
I'd rather definitely see them build it
in a gameplay direction first and
foremost and if they happen to tack on
like some sort of overarching narrative
that makes me question what I've been
doing that's really cool it's a bonus
but that's not what I'm looking for in a
game like that so right now I'm kind of
just expecting them to like you said
expand different directions gameplay
wise awesome thanks Mike thanks Aaron